Hey everyone, we are going to have a look at some moral hazard work problems.
Now what I'm going to be doing is just reading through some questions and figuring out what the answers are based off of what we are trying to do here.
And that is understand moral hazard.
So let's go ahead and let's jump into this first question.
It says, which scenario is an example of moral hazard in insurance?
So let's go through these answers.  To start with.
An insured homeowner neglects to install a security system knowing that losses from theft are covered.
I don't actually have to proceed any further because that is the answer because this is something that's taking place.
This is actions or behavior that's taking place after the contract has already been finalized.
And it's creating a situation for the insurance company in which they're going to be ended up paying out more because of the homeowner neglecting to actually do the security system there.
So again, it takes place after the contract.
So that's how we know that this one is going to be an example of moral hazard in insurance.
Our next question, what indicates moral hazard and health insurance behavior?
So let's go through these people choosing higher deductibles to lower their premiums.
No, that signals somebody who is going to be a little bit more careful because they have to pay a lot in those deductibles.
People visiting doctors more frequently when they have lower co pays.
Yeah, if you have a lower copay, you're not going to be having.
You're going to be doing it.
You're going to be engaged in some moral hazard because you're less likely to take care of yourself or be more prone to do things that are going to cause you to have accidents because you don't have a large payment that you have to pay at that doctor's office.
So you're more likely or more willing to visit the doctor's office more likely to take risk and so on.
Question number three here.
Which situation does not represent moral hazard?
An employee takes longer breaks than permitted because their manager is not around.
That is shirking.
That is moral hazard.
A worker uses safety equipment carelessly because they are covered by workplace insurance.
Again, that is going to be moral hazard.
An employee frequently calls in sick after maxing out their health benefits.
Yes, that is going to be moral hazard.
And then lastly, so this one has to be it.
A company invests in the best safety equipment available to protest, protect its workers.
Yeah, that is going to be our example of not moral hazard.
That's a company who's being proactive in trying to reduce moral hazard that would take place.
All right, next question.
How does moral hazard appear in loan agreements?
How does moral hazard appear in loan agreements?  Let's go through these.
A borrower maintains a good credit score to obtain future loans.
No, that is not going to be what we're looking for.
A borrower invests in a high risk business venture after securing the loan.  Yeah, there we go.
That is going to be our moral hazard because we are doing something after the fact, after the contract is taking place.
What we are looking for here is the fact that, hey, the bank's going, no, no, no, don't do that because you're likely to lose out on that and we're not going to recoup the loan from you.
So in that case, this is what we are looking for as moral hazard in loan agreements.
Okay, next question for us.
What is an example of shirking due to moral hazard at work?
We all have done this.
We all know we're on the Facebook or the X as it's now called, or the Instagram or the TikTok basic.
Can we still be on TikTok?  I don't know.
An employee spends less, spends time on personal activities during work hours when unsupervised.
We don't really need to read any further because that is a perfect example of what shirking is, is the other ways here a manager increases supervision.
That is a way to reduce shirking.
So that's monitoring.
Employees are rewarded with bonuses for exceeding their performance target.  No, no, no, no.
That would mean you would want a shirk.
And then lastly, a company implements strict attendance policies that is again designed to stop shirking.
All right, so our next question.
How does moral hazard relate to remote work?  Work shirking.  Oh, boy.
So, you know, since 2020, we have done more remote working as more people have engaged in remote working.
And you know, I think I do recall reading a study or an article somewhere where what was found is that people can actually get their work done in less than an eight hour day, like what you would normally have in an office.
So how does moral hazard relate to remote work shirking?
An employee minimizes work output at home knowing it's harder to be monitored.
Yeah, let's just go ahead and say, yes, that is our answer.
That, that's, that's exactly what's taking place.
I mean, the boss isn't going to be having a camera on your computer or whatever monitoring you all the time.
So yeah, that is going to be our answer there.
The other ones here, an employee uses software.
Employer uses software to monitor employee activity at home.  That would actually.
That would.  Well, let's see.
How could that one also be.
Oh, let's talk about shirking.  So.
So here we're looking at shirking.
This is just going to be monitoring as opposed as a way to deal with the shirking.
The actual shirking is taking place in a remote.
Workers are given clear performance metrics.
Yeah, I mean, if you can get all your work done in six hours instead of eight hours, I mean, then I guess that's okay.
An employee takes on additional projects to demonstrate productivity.
No, that's not going to be shirking.
All right, number.  Whatever this is.
How can bonus structures lead to moral hazard in shirking?
How can bonus structures lead to moral hazard in shirking?  Okay.
Bonuses are tied to specific measurable achievements.
All right, I don't think that's going to be our answer.
Because if you have a specific measurable achievement, you're going to try to get to that, and that's not going to cause you to shirk.
Employees receive an annual bonus that does not depend on individual performance metrics.
Yeah, that's our answer here.
If it doesn't depend on any type of performance metric, then guess what?
You are likely to shirk because you're still going to get that bonus anyway.
So, yeah, that's going to be our answer.
Bonus increase with the level of achieve targets.
No, you're not going to be shirking.
We still might, but your shirking is going to be a lot less than what would actually take place otherwise.
And then bonus distribution is directly linked to customer satisfaction ratings.
Man, that'd be kind of interesting if we did that with faculty.
We got bonuses tied to our student satisfaction ratings.
I just.  Oh, boy.
All right, last one.
What is an effective strategy to reduce moral hazard related to employee shirking?
I mean, I should have just put all the answers, the right answers as a.  I'm just even reading this.
I hadn't even said it out loud, and I know that's going to be the answer.
Implementing regular and random checks of employee workstations and activities.
Well, yeah, I mean, that is going to be monitoring.
That's going to be a way to eliminate or reduce the shirking that takes place.
And that also is going to help us reduce the moral hazard, reducing the number of supervisors.
Now, that increases shirking allowing more flexible hours without any form of monitoring that increases shirking, encouraging self reporting of productivity without verification.
Yeah, that is also going to be more of our shirking taking place there.  So there you go.
That was a total of, I believe, eight questions related to moral hazard and shirking and different things that are related and unrelated to them.
Hope you have enjoyed it and we'll catch you in our next one.
Or is this our last one?
Yes, this is our last one.  So adios.